For almost 10 years, Dos Equis has been engaging
beer consumers with its "Most Interesting
Man in the World" campaign, featuring an elegant
older man recalling mind-blowing life adventures
from the good ol' days.
Those videos have made 77-year-old American
actor Jonathan Goldsmith a pop culture celebrity.
But in an effort to attract a younger audience,
Dos Equis recently passed the prestigious
mantle to a younger actor, Augustin Legrand.
“Think anyone will ever be as interesting
as him?”
Here are a few things you don't know about
the new most interesting man in the world.
More modern
At 41 at the time of his hiring, Legrand is
more than 30 years younger than Goldsmith.
The new commercials highlight the contrast
right away: the previous versions basked in
past glories while vintage video footage of
his adventures plays.
But Legrand seems to show a more present man
of mystery.
Dos Equis told Ad Week,
"The new Most Interesting Man is a man of
our times, and in this first glimpse, he shares
hints of being a resourceful, rough and tumble
guy, who remains a jack-of-all-trades hero
that one would expect from the man bearing
this infamous title."
That, and this guy was busy.
“Bringo!”
A master of many tongues
Legrand is a French actor who boasts a trilingual
skillset, speaking English, French, and Spanish.
It's interesting to note that in his Dos Equis
debut, Legrand's first line is actually in
Spanish.
"It's hard to say."
The beer brand tells USA Today there's a reason
for that, saying,
"We're trying to reach a new audience.
The reality of the drinker base is it's much
more multicultural than ever.
And Spanish-dominant consumers are increasingly
important."
Muy bien, as they say.
Nearly the most boring man
Before he became the new Most Interesting
Man, Legrand almost became a total snooze
when he earned a Master's degree in tax law.
But by a weird turn of fate, Legrand was bitten
by the acting bug and enrolled at French drama
school Cours Florent in Paris.
He's since been featured on the big and small
screen since 2001, including a recurring role
in the French TV drama Odysseus, and the 2006
film Flyboys.
Actor and activist
As proof of his impressive moral character,
Legrand is also the co-founder of the Children
of Don Quixote, an organization dedicated
to raising awareness of France's homeless
population.
Beginning in 2006, the organization helped
to install 100 tents on a canal near the Seine,
and has repeated the installation multiple
times over the years.
Legrand's documentary on the topic received
an Amnesty Award nomination at the Copenhagen
International Documentary Festival.
He's also opened an inexpensive organic restaurant
in Paris, so his real life might be even more
interesting than the role he plays on TV.
New man, same narrator
While there's a new Most Interesting Man,
the company still plans on introducing the
video commercials with the same narrator,
Will Lyman.
"His beard alone has experienced more than
a lesser man’s entire body."
Lyman was chosen to keep the familiar voice
going forward in Legrand's era, according
to brand manager Andre Woldt, who said,
"We feel he is an important part of the campaign.
And while we want to evolve what interesting
means today, I think a few [tenets] of the
brand are very important to keep."
...and that apparently means keeping the same
guy who narrates The History Channel's most
questionable content.
"Deep sea UFOs continue to lurk through the
uncharted waters of Earth."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!